birz bircek 9 sınıf örerim jf kotar
okuluna YouTube'un en büyük CF kanalına
Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Paraf z takım okula
destek kampımızı bugün geldik 6 gününe
ne öğrenmiştik Önceki videoda ölçekleri
öğrenmiştik değil mi Bir de
projeksiyonları sonra o videodan sonra
hemen soru çözümü yapmıştık şimdi bugün
konumuz haritalarda dağılışları gösterme
yöntemleri Bakın bu haritalarda
dağılışları gösterme yöntemlerinin
sorusunu bundan sonraki videoda
çözmeyecek bu videonun içinde çözeceğiz
çünkü bu konu kısa bir konu bunun sorusu
da bir testlik bir soru ikisini
birleştirip tek videoda halledeceğiz
halletmek için ben kalemimi aldım
hazırım Sen de şurada beğen tuşu var Bak
şurada ona basacaksın hazırlanmak için
basmışsın hazırsındır o zaman ne diyoruz
Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir daha
asla unutma Niye bu kelimeyi
kullanıyoruz bu sloganı Yunus hocayla
bir defa öğren bir daha asla unutma Bunu
ne zaman anlayacaksın biliyor musun hiç
hiç böyle sınavdan önce hazırlanmadığı
bir sınavda tam böyle testte karşına
çıktığında yazılıda Aa aklıma geldi Bu
kodlamayla dediğin zaman anlayacaksın
Bir sene sonra o kavram aklına
geldiğinde anlayacaksın 4 sene sonra
tyt'ye hazırlanırken Aa ben bu
kavramların hepsini hatırlıyorum
dediğinde İşte o zaman anlayacaksın
Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir daha
asla unutma kelimesinin ne anlama
geldiğini diyoruz ve o zaman gelin şi
derse Paraf atalım geldik 6 gündeyiz hem
testini çözeceğiz hem konu anlatımını
yapacağız bunun şöyle gençler pdf'
imizin aynı böyle renkli çıktısını zedu
v.com sitesinden ücretsiz bir şekilde
indirebilirsiniz sadece bu pdf'i değil Z
takımının diğer branşların bütün pdf'ler
de oradan ind indirebilirsiniz onların
konu anlatımı da var şimdi bir önceki
dersle alakalı şöyle bir hatırlatma ve
bir bilgi söylemek istiyorum size bakın
ölçekler konusunu işlerken Aslında orada
uzunluk ve alan hesaplamaları diye bir
kısım var tam bizim konumuzun notumuz
sonuna denk geliyordu ben onu söylemeyi
unuttum yine kitabımızda da son kısma
denk geliyor küçük bir yer ayırmış ona
şimdi Aslında o geçmişte çok ayrıntılı
bir şekilde anlatılan bir konuydu
haritalarda uzunluk hesaplama
haritalarda alan hesaplama gibi böyle
saçma sapan bir sürü işlem yapıyorduk ve
o kadar yoruyordu ki öğrencileri nefret
ediyorlardı Coğrafyadan kaldırıldı MEB
kitabında ne yazıyor Biliyor musunuz
diyor ki uzunluk ve alan hesaplamalarına
artık biz teknolojiyle yapıyoruz diyor
ve kare kod koymuş altına teknolojiyle
nasıl yaptığının videosunu da göstermiş
O yüzden teknolojiyle yaptığımız bir
şeyi oturup öğrencilerin sizlerin öyle
uzunlukları hesaplayalım alanları
hesaplayalım diye uğraşmasına Gerek yok
inşallah öğretmenin Sana bunu
anlatmıyorsa bunu anlatmaya
çalışmıyordur anlatıyorsan da hocalarım
artık bunu anlatmayın MEB kitabı bile
ısrarla demiş Teknoloji gelişti demiş
bununla ölçün demiş göstereyim Şimdi
size nasıl ölçeceğiz şimdi E map bunu
kendi OG e Harita Genel Müdürlüğü'nün
yaptığı bir küre var aynı böyle
Google'ın Küresi gibi o kürede
gösteriyor nasıl ölçeceği gösteriyor O
kürede ama ben indirdim o küreyi Hatta
var şu an bilgisayarımda şöyle
yakınlaştırıp uzaklaştırmak çok zor
oluyor o yüzden orada göst
göstermeyeceğim orada size burada
göstereceğim aynısı Ama zaten bunun
aynısı gençler bakın bir yerin
Uzaklığını uzunluğunu Biz
hesaplayabiliyorum bakın bakın Şurayı
görüyor musunuz mesafe ve alan ölçümü
alıyorsun bunu mesela geliyorsun şuraya
Ben şimdi nereye gideceğim Diyarbakır'a
gideceğim şimdi bu videodan Sonra bir
video daha çekebilecek miyim Eee galiba
çekemeyeceğim Diyarbakır'a gideceğim
Diyarbakır'dan geldikten sonra çekeceğim
o videoyu Ekimin kaçı oldu ikisinde
çekiyorum bu videoyu Ekimin 7'si gibi
Diyarbakır'a yola çıkacağım 20'si gibi
geleceğim diğer videolar devam
ettireceğim Merak etmeyin şimdi
Instagram'dan takip ederseniz beni
oradan an ve an görürsünüz nerede
olduğumu şimdi Diyarbakır'a geld gim
şimdi Diyarbakır'dan nereye gidelim
Diyarbakır'a gideceğim mesela Diyarbakır
dilen şurada hes'e gideceğim Bakın
Gördünüz mü E hocam burada bak ölçüm
böyle yapılıyor bunun ölçümünü yaptık
Ama bakın burada uzunluk dakika olarak
göstermiş görüyor musunuz nasıl ölçüm
yapacağınızı öğretiyorum size ekranda
görünüyor mu evet şurada bir ok var Onu
göremiyorsunuz bakın açtım burada metre
kilometre fit mil hangisiyle göstermek
istiyorsanız gösterebiliyor musunuz
bakın 3.4 km varmış buradan buraya Ama
şunu unut unutmayın Gençler bu Kuş uçumu
uzak yani hiç yer şekilleri hesaba
katılmadan yapılan uzaklık bu ne
kadarmış 3.4 kymi İşte bu şekilde Biz
uzaklık hesaplamaları yapabiliyoruz
bakın bir tane daha yapayım size mesela
Diyarbakır Ulu Camii'nden şöyle
Diyarbakır Ulu cami'den hevsel
bahçelerine gideceğim 1.5 kreye yakınmış
gördünüz mü alan hesaplaması yapabiliyor
muyuz Evet bir yerin alanını da
hesaplayabiliyorum mesela nerenin
alanını hesaplayalım şurada bir tarla
var amcamız buraya koymuş bahçesini
tarlası da burada buranın alanını kaba
taslak olarak hesaplayabiliyorum
hesaplayalım bu sefer geliyorsun Bak
şöyle aldın mı bu uzunluk ölçüsünü aldım
bak Buralara gelip kısa kısa mesafelere
nokta koyuyorum ne kadar kısa mesafelere
nokta koyarsanız o kadar gerçekçi bir
sonuç çıkar bakın geliyorum görüyor
musunuz Yani şöyle koyarsanız sıkıntı
yok çünkü zikzak çizmede burada buradaki
alan zikzak çizmedin için hemen hemen
doğru hesapladım bakın zikzak çizse eydi
Mesela şurada bir zikzak çiziyor O zaman
böyle noktaları biraz daha yakın Koyu ki
o zikzak kısmını takip
edebileceğini de içine aldık şurada
bakın başladığım noktada bitirdim
gördünüz mü görüyor musunuz bakın
çevresi
0.98 km bölge 61000 mk metreye
çevirirsek 0.06 kmk hektar dersek 6
hektarlık bir yermiş Evet bu şekilde 61
b000 mky demiş Burası Bakın Gördünüz mü
adamın tarlası da bayağı yani bayağı
bayağı büyük bir tarlay mış böyle
ölçümler yapabiliyorsunuz şimdi o kısmı
Anladık mı Şimdi gelelim haritalarda
dağılışları göstermeye Gençler biz
haritalarda bir şey gösterirken bakın
böyle yani verileri haritaya aktarırken
böyle yöntem kullanıyoruz bakın noktasal
çizgisel alansal yöntem kullanıyoruz bu
sana sınavda sorulabilir Mesela ben sana
desem ki akarsuyu bana bir haritada
göster şöyle bir harita var bana burada
akarsuyu göster ne yaparsın akarsuyu
böyle nokta olarak mı gösterirsin Hayır
nasıl gösterirsin çizgi olarak
gösterirsin değil mi İşte biz böyle
verileri gösterirken kullandığımız bu
yöntemler nokta çizgi alansal Anlaştık
mı buraya bakın harita mesela burada
evleri bakın nasıl göstermiş nokta
olarak şurada bakın tarla var tarlayı
Sen nokta olarak göstermezsin biraz daha
alan olarak
alan olarak işaretlemek daha mantıklı
bütün ormanın alanını işaretlemek değil
mi bakın Burada yine bir akış var akışı
çizgi olarak işaretlemiş bize bunu
Anladık mı bakın noktada hangilerini
noktasal olarak işaretleyebilir diye bir
soru çıkabilir karşınıza bunu mantıken
yapacaksınız yani şimdi Sen tutup bir
akarsuyu nokta olarak göstermezsin
haritada değil mi Ama bir Sanayi Bölgesi
olsa Sanayi olsa Sanayi Bölgesi değil de
Sanayi fabrika bir tane fabrika olsa onu
nokta olarak koyarsın oraya değil mi
İşte Bunun yorumunu basit bir şekilde
yapacaksın mesela bakın nüfus Sanayi
tesisi tarım okul gibi yerleri nokta
olarak gösteriyoruz Biz biraz dah mantık
sorusu Bu çizgi olarak neyi
gösteriyormuş e Akarsu çizgi yol çizgi
il sınırları e Bunlar da çizgi Evet
rüzgarın yönü çizgi şeklinde gidiyor fay
hatları fay hattı demek depremlerin
olduğu yerlerde kırıklar oluyor ya o
kırık hatlarına da çizgi Zaten onlar
çizgi olarak gösteriyoruz alan olarak
daha geniş yerleri seçeceksin Gölü
mesela küçük bir nokta olarak koymak
doğru değil büyük bir göl genelde
genelde büyük oluyorlar alan olarak
koydum ovalar ormanlar idari bölgeler
bunları da alan olarak gösteriyoruz
haritalarda Tamam şimdi biz gençler
haritaları oluştururken farklı haritalar
oluşturmak zorundayız Çünkü kullanım
amacım oluşturma amacım farklı
olabiliyor ya bazen bir harita
oluşturacağım ben diyelim Ben de harita
oluşturuyorum Mesela bu harita
kitabımıza harita oluşturuyorum değil mi
Bazen sadece aynı renge boyuyorum illeri
ama bazen tarım haritası oluşturmam
gerekiyor Bu sefer nokta koyuyorum tarım
haritalarının olduğu yere ya da bazı
sembolleri daha büyük yapıyorum
haritaları farklı farklı şekilde
gösterebiliyor işte Bu sene yeni gelen
konumuz Burası büyük bir ihtimalle
sınavda da buradan soru gelecek ortak
sınavda da buradan 10 puanlık sorun çok
rahatlıkla çıkar karşına ne Bunlar Hocam
bakın korokromatik
Haritalar ne demek istiyor biliyor
musunuz şöyle karşınıza çıkmıştır sadece
tek bir renk var bir şey göstermek
istiyorsun tamam mı burada Mesela
büyükşehir belediyeleri demiş büyükşehir
belediyesi olan illeri tek bir renge
boyuyorsun burada amaç ne biliyor
musunuz alan göstermek herhangi böyle
bir derece göstermek yok yani orada daha
çok var vardır burada daha az vardır
bunu kademeli olarak göstereyim Bir
sayısal bir derece göstereyim yok bir
yoğunluk gösterme var mı şurası daha
yoğundur Burası daha az yoğundur böyle
bir şey var mı yok Sadece alan
gösteriyor bakın sadece alan yani Ankara
büyükşehir mi Büyükşehir Bu kadar bitti
Ankara'nın hepsini aldı Sadece alanını
gösteriyor herhangi bir yoğunluğu
göstermiyor başka nasıl örnek
verebiliriz buna Mesela Türk ya Yunus
hoca'ın gittiği bugüne kadar gittiği
şehirler K kromatik haritadır bugüne
kadar gittiğim şehirleri diğer videoda
göstermiştim sana Şuradaki haritamda
değil mi kazıyordu onları O ne bir şehre
gittiysem kazıdım onu Bak sadece iki
tane ordu ve tokat' gitmiştim şimdi
Diyarbakır'a giderken de kazıyacağım onu
ne yapıyorum sadece diyorum ki Yunus
hocanın gittiği şehirler alan olarak
gösterdim bir yoğunluk herhangi bir
derece gösterme bir şey var mı Yok
gittiğim şehirler tak alan olarak
gösterdim ha Peki hocam ben bunu aklımda
nasıl tutacağım krok kromatik bilmem ne
şöyle yapacaksın bak krok romatik
diyeceksin buna tamam mı krok romatik
diyeceksin krok romatik ha hocam Roma
Roma Devleti gibi diyeceksin Yunus hoca
Roma gibi tek tek haritaları fethediyor
Hatta ben o harita videomu şuraya
koyayım da tam orayı anla Bak şimdi bu
gez kazı şeklinde bir harita bakın ilk
tokata gittik Sonra anket açtık yine
Tokat'ın yanına gittik sonra 3 anket
açtım az daha yine Sivas çıkıyordu
Tokat'ın yanındaydı Allah'tan Sivas
çıkmadı Şimdi Önümüzdeki gezi
Diyarbakır'a olacak gördün mü O haritayı
şimdi ben ne yaptım sadece bir alanı tık
tık fethettim Roma gibi fethettim bir
Alanı fethettim işaretledim buradaki Püf
nokta bu sana biri krok romatik harita
dediği zaman krok romatik harita dediği
zaman ha hocam Roma Roma Savaş fethetmek
Yunus hoca Romalı Yunus hoca ne yapmıştı
Türkiye'deki bütün şehirleri Feth
ediyordum fethedince de tık alanları
alanları boyuyordum alan diyeceksin alan
haritası tık bir şehri seçeceğim bir
şehri tek tek bir işaretleme var
herhangi bir yoğunluk Yok bir şey yok
alan buradaki önemli nokta şudur gençler
alansal dağılışı gösterdi yoğunluk ve
miktar Yok burada mantık bu Tamam test
çözeceğiz şimdi oturacak kafanda merak
etme Türkiye'deki Linet yatakları mesela
değil mi büyükşehir belediyeleri nerede
varsa bunlar geçelim buradaki mantığı
anlamışsınızdır Bakın aynı renk sadece
alanı boyuyor hiç yoğunluk yok miktar
yok üzerinde fazla duruyorum Çünkü Bunu
anlaman lazım senin çıkacak sınavda izop
leti değil ilk önce korop lei göstereyim
sana çünkü koro kok romatik le koplet
karıştırılabilir kopti göstereyim sonra
diğerini göstereyim Bakın bu çok kolay
dikkat edin yine korok romatik TKİ gibi
bir harita var ama o harita tek bir
renge değil mi tek bir renge o mavi de
olmayabilirdi siyah da olabilirdi o
haritadaki önemli değil tek bir renge
Roma korok romatik Feth ediyordum ben
tek bir renge boyuyordum alanı
boyuyordum burada biraz daha iş fark
burada artık işin içine yoğunluk miktar
giriyor ne kadar derecesini ver bana
diyor bakın Türkiye'de ki Mısır üretim
alanları dikkat edin bir rengin
dereceleri var burada bakın griden açık
daha da koyuya doğru giden bir mavi renk
var burada bu sefer derece derece koydum
ben bu haritada bu haritanın farkı bu
Mısır üretim ben baktığımda Aa burada
daha en az bu gri deymiş sonra
buradaymış sonra artıyor burada daha da
arttı burada daha da arttı şurada
Konya'da artık tavan seviyesine çıktı
bakın dikkat edin bu sefer ne var bir
derecelendirme var değil mi Bir
dereceleme soktum ben bunu işte Bu
haritalar Bu haritalar koplet haritalar
koplet kodlamaya bak koplet palet palet
palet renk paleti var burada renk paleti
Hayatını kurtaracak senin şu kelime
koplet koplet renk paleti renk paleti
nasılı gençler renk paletlerini
görmüşsünüzdür açıktan koyuya Doğru
giden renk paletleri Alın size renk
paleti yani koroplet dediğinde Aa k
palet renk paleti hocam bunlar
diyeceksin kroma bak kroma renk Aslında
orası nereden biliyorum ben bunu diyorum
ya Yunanca kelime kroma doğru kroma
kromdan büyük bir ihtimalle renkten
geliyor o kelime koplet palet renk
paleti demek ki böyle renk paleti
şeklinde böyle açıktan koyuya Doğru
giden bir harita gördüğünde kop Plate
diyeceksin bak E şimdi açıktan koyuya
gidiyorsa bu miktar belirtir değil mi
yoğunluk belirtir değil mi Çünkü açıkta
daha az var koyudur daha fazla miktar
var demek ki içinde yoğunluk var içinde
ezberlemeden bak mantıken çıkarttım
koruk romatik Aa Roma Roma'yı Feth
ediyordu Yunus Hoca Yunus hoca Roma gibi
Feth ediyordu fethettiği yeri tık
kazıyordu haritada tık kazıyordu
haritada ama nicelik yani eee bir
yoğunluk bir miktar var mıydı yok tık
kazıdım alanını tık alanını kazıyordu
alan gösteriyordum sadece korokromatik
koroplet Al sana kodlama yeni yaptım bu
kodlamayı ha Çünkü bu konu yeni bir konu
bu konuyu oturdum nasıl kodlayabilirim
diye düşündüm yaptım kodlamasını Evet K
koplet de işi tamam izoplet Bakın yine
palet var burada Demek ki bir renk
olacak yine burada izometrik metre bir
ölçüm olacak Bak şimdi burada ne var
biliyor musunuz bu izola metrik bir
ölçüm var Tamam palet He hocam Burada da
bir renk renk değişimi var E o zaman
renk değişimi bu renklere göre bir şey
varsa bunlar da o zaman yoğunlukları ve
dağılımları miktarları gösterecek değil
mi Bir renk değişimi varsa Peki hocam bu
İzo bunun diğerinden farkı ne İzo
gençler eş demek Bunu izs konusunda
göreceğiz bundan bir sonraki videoda
izohipste göreceğiz Eş yükselti eğrileri
demek eş çizgiler demek İzo i demek Heh
gelelim şimdi kodlamam iz demek izoplet
dediğinde birisi sana izoplet ha hocam
palet var renk paleti var burada demek
renklerle gösterilmiş bir derecelendirme
olacak ama bu sefer izle yap bunu diyor
bana bak iz iz le yap diyor ne demek iz
izden kastımız şu çizgiler bak iz bu
Eğer bunları gör a hocam bunlar iz çizgi
izler Bunlar iz iz işte şurada
gördüğünüz bu harita izler var burada
bakın izler iz var mı var ha iz hemen
sonra palet gibi burası hocam farklı
renklerle farklı şeyler gösterilmiş
izoplet hocam o zaman burası diyorsun
Anladık mı ipucunu bu haritayı nasıl
bulacağınızı Tamam güzel anladığınızı
düşünüyorum etkinlik yapacağız bunlarla
merak et etmeyin bakın Burada da yine iz
var bakın görüyor musunuz iz var iz var
ve renklerle bir derecelendirme
yapmışlar İzo palet A pardon izoplet o
zaman diyeceksin işte yunus hocayla bir
defa öğren bir daha asla unutma gelip
sana burada izop leti klei maddelerini
yazıp ezberletmişlerdi
ileride anlayacaksın Biz dersi derste
öğreniyoruz gençler bakın dersi derste
öğrenmek farklı bir şey tutup burada
kopti Sen kendin maddelerini yazıp
ezberlemeye kalktığında o o zaman işi
sen yapmış oluyorsun benim görevim sana
anlatmak değil sana öğretmek bu dersten
çıktığında senin kafanda bir şey
kalmamışsa o zaman ben sana bunu
öğretememişim deir anlatmışım dır
anlatmak başka bir şeydir anlatman başka
bir şeydir öğretmen başka bir şeydir Ben
öğretmen olmaya çabalıyorum O yüzden
uzuyor bazen video bazen saçmalıyorum
bazen saçma saçma kodlamalar yapıyorum
ama unutma Bunların hepsi şu an bu
zamanını kaybediyorsun sen şu an bir
zaman ayırıyorsun bu videoya bu zamanını
ayırdığın Bu videoda öğren bunu Bu
videoda öğrendikten sonra kendin
çalışmana çok zaman gerek kalmasın Ama
sen videodan dinleyip ya da sınıfta
dinleyip Ondan sonra kendin çalışarak
öğreniyorsun Demek ki karşında sana
anlatılıyor öğretilmiyor anlatmak
anlatmam başka bir şeydir öğretmen başka
bir şey o yüzden kodlamaları saçma
demeyin hepsi işinize yarayacak hiç
merak etmeyin buraya kadar tamam mı
Zaten zor olanlar onlardı tekrar edelim
mi bak korok romatik aa Roma Roma Feth
ediyordu Yunus hoca da Feth ediyordu
Türkiye'nin illerini alanları kazıyordu
Yunus hoca sadece alanı kazıyordu
yoğunluk yok miktar yok tek bu kadar
koroplet kop palet renk paletleri hocam
koroplet renk paletleri vardı haritada
farklı farklı derecelerde renkler varsa
yoğunluk gösterir miktar gösterir
izoplet ha hocam yine palet var Farklı
renkler var ama bu sefer iz çizgiler
izler olacak bu renkleri gösterirken
diyeceksin o işte bu kadar noktalama
haritaları Bunlar çok basit gençler adı
üstünde noktalama haritası Mesela ne
demek diyor ki bir tane nokta diyor
tamam mı Şöyle bir nokta 1 milyonluk
neymiş burada Mesela pirinç
üretimiyle varmış Bu ülkede diyorum ya
burada Sakarya nehrinin çevresinde 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 14 milyon
Pirinç üretimi varmış burada Tamam bunu
gösteriyor burada her nokta bir sayıya
karşılık geliyor gördünüz mü Bu sadece
bir noktayla gösterilmeye bilil kareyle
daireyle üçgenle de gösterilebilir
unutmayın biz buna yine noktalama
haritası diyoruz ama evet noktalar
fazlaysa yoğunluk da fazladır Tamam
mesela şuraya bakın yoğunluk burada az
bir tane var gibi noktayı da öğrendik
bakın bunun da ismi üstünde oransal
Sembol bir sembol seçeceksin ama onu
oransal olarak büyütüp küçültecek
oransal Sembol bu kadar bakın Ne yapmış
bu sefer bir şeyi göstermek için neyi
göstermiş burada Türkiye'de endüstri
tesislerini göstermiş bakın Burada da bu
oranın bü büyüklüğünü gösteriyor yani
bir miktarı var yine burada ne yaptı
sembolü büyüttü bu sefer He bu çok
büyükmüş o zaman bu işte 850n
üstündeymiş diyoruz oransal Sembol
sembolü büyüterek oransal olarak
büyüterek yapılıyormuş bu kadar adı
üstünde akış haritası burada gençler
bakın bir trafik Ticaret Turizm Akarsu
Akarsu ne yapar bir akış yapar değil mi
bir akış rüzgarlar bir akış yapar bakın
şurada mesela haritanın üstünde Şurayı
görüyor musunuz bir akış var mesela bir
geminin gittiği limanlar gösterilecek
haritada Al sana bir akış akış haritası
böyle ok gördüğün zaman Bunlar da akış
haritasını ifade ediyor mesela bakın göç
Yolları göç miktarını gösteriyor bak
Rüzgar yağış sevve taşkınların Geliş
yönü aslında bir ok lazım bize ok olarak
gösteriliyorsa akış var nokta varsa
nokta da ama bunların büyüklükleri aynı
büyüklükleri aynı noktasal noktalama
haritaları böyle bir sembol büyük bir
sembol küçük bir sembol oransal Sembol
bu kadar Evet Bir de kartogram haritalar
var buraya görselini koymamış görselini
göstereyim sana Bakın şimdi Gençler bu
kartogram haritası yine kodlayaz bunu
merak etme kartogram gram gramına göre
gramına göre bulunduğu yeri büyütüyorsun
Bak mesela İstanbul nüfus miktarı Tamam
mı Şimdi İstanbul'un nüfus miktarı çok
büyük gramını gramı çok kartogram gramı
çok büyük gramı çok büyükse İstanbul'u
çok büyük yapıyorsun şek Bakın bu
Türkiye haritası ha Türkiye haritasının
şekli komple değişmiş Çünkü şurada
nüfusu gramına göre değiştiriyor
şehirlere yayıyor bak gramına göre
Ankara gramı bayağı fazlaymış bakın
Ankara'nın da Iğdır'a bakın gramı
küçükmüş kartogram ha gramına göre büyüt
hocam küçült hocam diyecek küçült
diyeceksin gramına göre yapılan bu antik
tın tink haritalar Bunlar antik kuntik
haritalar gramına göre yapılan bu antik
kuntik harita işte çok değişik bir
harita Evet bunu da anladık değil mi
Evet bir alıştırma yapalım mı belirli
alanlarda yapılacak araştırmalar
sonucunda elde edilen verilerin coğrafi
olay ve unsurların mekansal dağılış
harita üzerinde gösterilebilir mekansal
veriler haritalara aktarılırken noktasal
çizgisel ve alansal olmak üzere üç
yöntem kullanılır Buna göre bir bölgede
aşağıdaki unsurların gösterilmesinde
etkili olan yöntemi yazınız mesela orman
ormanı ne ile gösterirsin Sen orman
büyük bir alan değil mi alanla
gösterirsin kara ve demir yolu e Demir
yolunu böyle çizgiyle göstermez misin O
zaman çizgisel diyeceksin alansal
çizgisel Sanayi tesisi tık bir tane Ee o
zaman noktasal diyeceksin Evet sınavda 5
puanlık sorunuzu bu devam edelim bir
etkinliğimiz daha var yine okul
kitabında da bu etkinlik var bu
etkinliği okul kitabından önce burada
gör bakın ok işareti koymuş Ee akış
haritası değil mi akış akış haritası
bakın buraya nokta koymuş nokta ve
bunların böyle büyüklükleri farklı
farklı değil nokta koymuş nokta sal adı
üstünde nokta sal Bak şimdi farklı renk
paletleri var görüyor musunuz ha bu plet
Tamam plet koplet mi yoksa izoplet mi Aa
izler var hocam burada iz iz kalem
çizgileri var izoplet izoplet Harita
bakın Kodlama nasıl işe yarıyor görüyor
musunuz Evet bu ne E hocam Yunus hocanın
Roma'yı fethettiği gibi korokromatik
harita niye kazımış direkt Yunus hoca
alanı sadece kazımış orduyu kazımış
Tokatı kazımış diğer akırı kazıyacak bak
Sadece alanı kazıyor korok korok
romatik Tamam başta aklına gelmeyecektir
korokromatik Benim de gelmiyordu yeni
bunları böyle kodladım Ama zamanla
oturuyor kok romatik koplet böyle ben de
o yüzden baskılayarak söylüyorum ki
kafanda iyice yer etsin diye bakın
burada bir sembol var ama bunların
bazıları büyük bazıları küçük ha bir
oran var oransal Sembol bu tarafa geldim
ya burada yine bir palet var Farklı
farklı renklerle gösterilmiş ha hocam
palet var burada bu sefer ama koplet
palet
koplet Tamam Evet bunu da yaptık Bu
sorumuzu da çözelim şöyle aşağıdaki
haritada Hatta şöyle yapalım Bu sorunun
çözümünü size bırakıyorum şıklara yazın
Nedenini de açıklayın ama tamam Nedenini
de açıklayarak şıklara yazın burada
Dersimiz bitti şimdi Şu üstteki
kitabımızdaki bu testin bu konunun
sorularını testlerini çözeceğiz O yüzden
bu testi çözmedim yoksa çözerim zaten
test çözeceğiz şimdi bu Bunu size
bırakıyorum gelsin testimiz Şimdi burada
test 5'i açıyorsunuz sayfa sayfa 37
şimdi bir önceki konuda ölçekler vardı
değil mi o ölçeklerle alakalı şurada bir
34 soru çözeceğiz hatırlamak için sonra
az önce gördüğümüz konuyla alakalı
soruları çözeceğiz ilk önce bir şu ölçek
kısmını bir kere daha hatırlayalım
yukarıda verilen yerlerin aynı boyuttaki
kağıtlara kağıdın tamamını kapsayacak
şekilde ayrı ayrı haritaları çizilmiştir
bu haritalarla ilgili olarak
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi söylenemez bunu
somutlayıcı
Ada Türkiye Asya Şimdi ben bunları aynı
boyuttaki kağıtlara sığdıracak mışım
Tamam mı Aynı boyuttaki kağıtlara
Hangisini daha fazla küçültürüm şimdi
Asya en büyük Asya değil mi Asya çok
büyükse Asya'yı ben çok küçültm lazım O
zaman ben buna şöyle paydası çok
küçültülecek bir şey yazdım gördünüz mü
O zaman ben bunu bu kadar fazla
küçültüyor küçük bir harita kalacak
elimde Türkiye şimdi burayı silelim
Türkiye Asya'dan sonra daha büyük olan o
zaman onu biraz daha az küçültecek şöyle
500.000 de O zaman o biraz daha büyük
kalacak değil mi Gökçeada H Gökçeada
küçük bir yer onu böyle az defa
küçülttüm o Gökçeada daha büyük kaldı az
küçülttüğümde
Bakın bu Büyük ölçekli Bunlar da küçük
ölçeğe büyükten küçüğe doğru gidişi
büyük harita Büyük ölçekli harita Evet
bu haritalarla ilgili olarak aşağıd
hangisi söylenmez bunu somutluk sonra
zaten Hadi bakalım çözemem Gökçeada
haritası Çok ayrıntı gösterir niye
haritaya bakın kocaman doğru Bu kadar
basit çözmek işte somutlayıcı Asya
haritasının öl ölçek paydası daha
büyüktür Asya haritasına bakın 1 milyon
sadece bakarak çözüyorum Neden Çünkü
somutluk ellerde somutlamaya
çözdüm Eğer ki ezberlemeye kalkarsanız
Eğer ki bunu bu şekilde somutlamaya
öğrenemezsiniz İşiniz zor Asya
haritasında 1 cimlik uzunluk gerçekte
daha kısa uzunluğa karşılık gelir şimdi
gençler bakın Asya Burası Asya'daki 1
cmlik uzunluğa bakın küçük harit ya bu
bak Asya'daki 1 cmlik uzunluk gerçekte
diyor ne diyor gerçekte daha kısa
uzunluğa karşılık gelir bakın bir de
şunda 1 cmlik uzunluk yapayım hangisinde
gerçekte daha uzundur Asya'daki de daha
uzundur Asya'daki 1 cimlik uzunluk Asya
bu Asya'daki 1 cimlik uzunluğu gerçek
hayatta bakarsak kilometrelerce çıkar
ama Gökçeada'nın haritasındaki 1 cmlik
uzunluk daha küçük görünür yanlış bu O
yüzden Evet Asya daha büyük Çünkü 1 cimi
devasa bir alanı gösterir Asya'da Evet
Türkiye haritasının ölçeği Gökçe adanın
kine göre küçüktür bak Gökçe ıni büyük
bu küçük Gökçe adanın kine göre küçük
Evet Gökçe Ada haritasının küçültme
oranı daha azdır Evet bakın Gökçe Ada
100 defa küçültülmüş küçültme oranı daha
az cevap geçelim diğer soruya gerçek
alan Yeryüzü şekillerinin tüm eğim
engebesi ile beraber toplam yüzey
alanıdır izdüşümsel alandan ise ngb
faktörünün ortadan kaldırılarak her
yerin düzmüş gibi kabul edildiği alandır
bir yerin gerçek alanı ile iz düşü alanı
arasındaki fark az ise o yerin o yerde
engebe azdır bunu konuşmuştuk bunu
anlatmıştım sana Hatta kodlamış tık
nasıl Şimdi göstereyim sana bu bu Buna
göre haritalarda verilen illerin
hangilerinin gerçek yüzölçümü ile iz
düşüm yüzölçümü arasındaki fark daha
fazladır gerçekle iz düşüm alanı
arasındaki fark daha fazladır diyorsa o
zaman burası yüksek engebelidir diyorduk
değil mi yüksek engebeli dağlık yer O
zaman ben burada dağlık yerleri
bulacağım Konya çevresini sana harita
çalışması yapmıştım Bir önceki derste ne
demiştik düz demiştik Burası İstanbul
düz olan yer demiştik bir de şu
Güneydoğu Anadolu düzlü Ama bakın 3
numaranın olduğu yer 2 numar numaranın
olduğu yer dağlık bölgelerde bakın çıktı
karşımıza 2 ve 3te daha fazladır dedik 2
ve 3 Sivas ve Van yani cevabımız C
geçelim diğer soruya a donmuş yine benim
ekran şöyle cevabımız C geçelim diğer
soruya küçük ölçekli hazırlanmış
haritalarda küçültme oranı daha fazladır
Buna göre küçük ölçekli haritalarla
ilgili yargılarından hangileri yanlış
olur küçük ölçek diyor bana şöyle
getirdim somutlayıcı
o zaman çok fazla küçültülmüş dedim
somutlamaya
dır dar ne demekti küçük alan Mesela bir
ilçe diyelim ilçe ilçe dardır Sen şimdi
ilçeyi 1 milyon defa küçültm gerek olur
mu Olmaz geniş alan olması lazım 1
milyon defa küçültmenin dünya gibi geniş
alanları biz böyle küçültürüz bu kadar
çok küçültürüz o yüzden bu yanlış hata
oranı fazladır Evet 1 milyon defa
küçültmüş harita küçücük kalmış hata
yapacak o zaman Evet hata oranı fazla
doğru ayrıntı gösterme gücü Azdır Sen şu
küçücük haritada ayrıntı görebilir misin
göremezsin doğru izohips Aralık değeri
büyüktür izohips konusu bir sonraki konu
o yüzden bu öncülü bilmene gerek yok Bir
sonraki konuda öğreneceksin bunu bunu
biliyormuş bilmiyormuş gibi varsay ölçek
paydasındaki rakam büyüktür bakın
paydadaki rakam büyük doğru Bu da doğru
Bu da doğruydu zaten 1 numara yanlış
oldu Cevabımı geçelim diğer soruya
İtalya'ya ait yukarıda verilen haritalar
hakkında aşağıdakilerden Hang yanlıştır
somutlayıcı
küçültülmüş o zaman hemen bunu somutluk
haritaya küçük ölçekli harita bu büyük
kalmış o zaman az küçültülmüş dedim
büyük bir harita Büyük ölçekli harita bu
kadar Evet hata oranı 2 numaralı
haritada daha fazladır Evet daha fazla
küçültüldü isse daha fazla Hata
yapacağım çünkü küçültüyor hata
yapabilirim 1 numaralı Haritanın ölçeği
büyüktür bakın Büyük ölçekli harita
Büyük ölçekli harita doğru ölçeği
küçülen haritanın Kağıt ebatı büyür
ölçeği küçülmüş bakın küçük ölçek küçük
ölçek ölçeği küçülürse Kağıt ebatı
küçülüyor muu Demek ki büyümüyor muu
yanlış bakın bir
somutlastirmak haritadaki uzaklık
değişir ama gerçekteki değişmez
İtalya'nın bir ucundan bir ucuna
gideceğim bak haritadaki uzaklık Bak
burada da böyle haritadaki uzaklık
değişti değil mi Biri uzun biri kısa
gerçekte uzaklık değişir mi Roma'nın şey
İtalya'nın kuzeyinden güneyine değsem
gerçekteki uzaklığı değiştiremezsin ki
evet cevabımız C geçelim diğer soruya
İstanbul'un aşağıdaki ölçekleri çizilen
haritasın hangisi daha geniş bir alan
kaplar bunlara harita çizelim 3 milyon
defa o 50 milyon defa küçültülmüş
küçücük bir harita çizdim 30 milyon defa
Biraz daha büyük olur 3 milyon defa
Biraz daha büyük kalır 300.000 defa daha
büyük Kalır çünkü Daha az küçültüyor
dikkat edin 30.000 defa en büyük kalır
hangisi daha geniştir a şıkkı 30.000
defa 30.000 defa küçültüldüğü için
harita büyük kalacak cevapa geçelim
diğer soruya Heh Hah geldik artık
bugünkü konunun sorularına coğrafi olay
olgu ve unsurlar haritada sembollerle
ifade edilir uzaktan algılama
teknikleriyle elde edilen mekansal
veriler haritalara AKT aktarılırken
noktasal çizgisel alansal olmak üzere üç
çeşit yöntem kullanılır aşağıdan
hangisinde mekansal verilerin haritaya
aktarılmasında kullanılan yöntem
yanlıştır elektrik direğini noktayla
gösterirsin değil mi Akarsu çizgidir
Evet Sanayi Bölgesi diyor bakın Biz
derste anlatırken Sanayi tesisi demiştik
Sanayi tesisi nokta olur küçük bir alan
ama Sanayi Bölgesi sanayi bölgesi büyük
yeri kapsar bölge diyor bakın Sanayi
tesisi demiyor O yüzden alan olur evet
doğru volkanik konisi nokta Evet
mantıklı Sıra Dağlar çizgi platolar
çizgi platoyu öğreneceksin lerde merak
etme Ova ovalar çok büyük düz ovaları
düşün nokta olarak gösteremezsin alan
olarak göstermen gerekiyor cevap A ama
diğerlerini de yaparım öğren Göl çizgi
ya Göl büyük bir yer alan olarak
gösterirsin ülke sınırı alan Hayır ülke
sınırında çizgi gösterirsin binalar
Nokta doğru fay hatı çizgidir tarım
alanları alansal doğru elektrik direğe
nokta koyarsın yola çizgi atarsın
ormanları da alan olarak görsin Evet
güzel bir soruydu cevapçı geçelim diğer
soruya bakalım şimdi haritaları
anlayabilmiş misin Buna göre Türkiye'de
nüfusun nüfusun illere göre dağılışını
dereceli renklendirme yaparak göstermek
isteyen bir kartograf hangisini kullanır
dereceli göster ha dereceli renk yapacak
o zaman nüfusun dağılışını dereceli bir
renkle gösterecek petle gösterecek
paletle gösterecek değil mi izometrik
diyor ve burada bakın illere göre
dağılışı var yani şehirleri farklı
renklerle göstermesi lazım plet ama
çizgi plati ile değil Çünkü şehirleri
göstereceğim Coro pl ile göstereceğim
bunları değil mi Coro plet haritalar
cevap Bursa geçelim diğer soruya
noktalama haritaları ile ilgili
aşağıdakilerden hangisi söylenemez ne
yapıyorduk şehirler vardı nokta
koyuyorduk mekansal bir verinin
dağılışını göstermek için sembollerin
kullanıldığı haritadır Evet nokta bir
semboldür değil mi üçgende
kullanılabilir karede kullanılan
semboller daire kare üçgende olabilir
doğru harita üzerindeki her bir nokta
belirli bir miktarı temsil eder 1 milyon
ton pirinci gösteriyordu bir nokta
mesela doğru coğrafi unsurun değerine
göre boyutu değişen bak sembollerdir
boyutu değişen semboller değil bunlar
boyut değişiyor mu Hayır hep nokta
boyutu değişen semboller oransal
semboller vardı hani şöyle Oran Oran
göst gösteriyordu onu söylüyor bu o
değil oransal Sembol haritasının tanımı
bu bu değil bu cevap d nokta sayısının
fazla olduğu alanlar Yoğunluğun fazla
olduğu yerlerdir Evet nokta burada çok
fazlaysa yoğunluk fazladır cevap de
geçelim diğer soruya farklı dağılış
yöntemlerine göre hazırlanan tematik
haritaların ait olduğu harita türleri
aşağıdan hangisine doğru olarak
verilmiştir Bakın şimdi gençler şu
haritaya bir bakın Ne var burada bak
renklere göre bir çizgi şeyler var değil
mi derecelendirmeler var bir palet renk
paleti var palet hocam o zaman bu çizgi
palet mi Hayır hocam çizgi değil bu
ülkelere göre yapmışlar izoplet değil o
zaman io izoplet değil koplet koplet
bakın koplet koplet olacak ikinci harita
zaten hiçbir tanesinde yok yani
cevabımız a diğerine bakalım
korokromatik bakın alanı boyamış Sadece
bu bir derece değil Bak bunlar renk
paletleri değiller bunlar bir dereceyi
mi gösteriyor yani böyle 1 5 10 15 gibi
bir dereceyi mi gösteriyor Hayır Hint
kültürü tak alan olarak boyamış aynı
benim haritamı kazıdığım alanı mı
kazıyordu farklı renk çıkıyordu ya aynı
öyle düşünün burada farklı renk olması
Onun bir derece göstermek için farklı
renk koymamış alanı göstermiş tık alan
gösterim sana tık alan göstermiş
korokromatik fethetmiş alanları
cevabımız a şıkkı Evet bir sonraki konu
izohipsler olacak en sevdiğim konulardan
bir tanesi Evet bu konuyu inşallah
anlamışsındır anlatabilmişimdir İnşallah
kodlamalarla hafıza teknikleriyle
mantığıyla
somutlayıcı
bir şeydir anlatmak farklı bir şeydir
bunu kendiniz çalışmaya başladığınızda
sınavlarda yazılılarda anlayacaksınız
diyoruz ve Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren
bir daha asla unutma deyip bir sonraki
bu derse de Paraf attık Bir sonraki
derste görüşmek üzere